hello so baby number three is on the way
yeah my wife is gonna love that intro
yeah she should be a little scared I
always think like because I have two
well I'm outnumbered because I'm single
now but like but it's a different thing
when you're outnumbered you're like no
one's there to like you know you only
have so many arms yes everyone says like
on the first baby they're like oh
congratulations the second baby they're
like congratulations on the third day
there's like a question mark at the end
yeah congratulations yeah
um where should I send the flower yeah
but uh we're excited my wife is uh let
me just take this moment on National
Television to say how beautiful amazing
she is
that's exciting though it is cool like
your family's just getting even bigger
that's cool yeah check in with me in
about yeah and you're gonna be like when
you're tired yeah it is cool though
because the siblings like I have two
kids and they literally want me to have
another baby they get excited they want
a baby in the house that's like how I
wanted my parents to get a dog so bad
and I was like I will participate like I
will walk the dog yeah I will see that I
did nothing no the whole I think I
walked that dog one time my daughter
suckered me into that as well I think
she prepped me if you should have a baby
and I was like oh
she was like or how about just a puppy
and I was like you're good I was like
okay so we got another one and she said
she'd help and she lied
um as a parent though are you Pro um
like screen time are you like Pro that
or like are you trying to you know Steer
clear of it we're trying to do as little
screen time as possible we were real
like no screen time people that's how we
all start yeah exactly yeah and then
you're like I need to pee yeah exactly
watch exactly but um wait did your
parents let you have screen time did you
watch TV no I am a uh product of
it was not zero screen time my mom loved
old movies yeah like another wonderful
woman I'd love to shout out and uh she
only let me watch classic movies which
sounds like a good move and was
ultimately great that I wasn't watching
a lot of TV yeah but I only watched old
movie I liked a lot of Cary Grant a lot
of Danny K yeah but I would go into
school and like one time like in seventh
grade I used the term man alive which is
like a you know when some bad happens
you go man alive in like the 40s
and I I started to realize like TV is
like how you normalize people they get
to know like how what the vernacular is
like now yeah and so I went to boarding
school uh when I was a teenager and then
I watched TV for like three years
non-stop to catch up to catch up and say
oh this is how people you're right
modern day talk right yeah I think
you're right though that is like how
friendships like you talk about the same
thing you have this oh did you see that
episode when this happened that is your
truth all the kids are saying yeah did
you see him live in color did you see
yeah Saturday live yeah I had no idea
what they were talking about and then
and then I just like binged uh
everything that had ever been made once
I was away but anyway my mom was
wonderful I'm glad she did it I think
she had great taste is what that is yeah
actually I didn't tell you this is uh my
mom told me that uh Saltines were
cookies
because I was like I feel like my mom
did that when we used to do this it was
like Poor Man's Dessert and you'd have
like a little butter and like a
marshmallow and you'd put it in the
microwave and it was like dessert yeah
my mom just thought like I mean she all
the right idea she was like let's keep
these kids healthy and so she I'd have a
cookie please and she can be a saltina's
yum and then and then when I was like
six or something I went on my first
sleepover to a kid's house and this kid
was like that's not a cookie
this is again it was like an Oreo and I
was like what is that and I she had to
come pick me up because I couldn't sleep
like yeah it's so much sugar in myself
like the whole thing of Oreos yeah yeah
um but did your mom make you take
classes or anything like you know like
sports or music or anything well uh this
was something that a lot of kids did at
this school I grew up at in Connecticut
um there's like a cotillion like
ballroom dancing you definitely weren't
poor
because nope no poor people even know
what Cotillion is like I still don't
you're not wrong Kelly but uh but it was
uh it wasn't my thing just to let you
know like my I wasn't into it but it was
the only thing that boys and girls could
do in that town together it was I I
don't know some guys in the movie
Footloose like like wait what it was uh
no no this was a pro dance thing but but
sadly it was just like ballroom dancing
and I was cool it was not cool but it
was uh it was again I'd seen in these
movies I watched growing up so I thought
oh that'll be cool and then I was so bad
at it I kind of there was a kid who um
on National Television I will call Frank
but that's not his name and you know who
you are Frank who like made fun of me a
lot like because because I didn't get
the ballroom dancing steps right or
whatever I still think I was cooler than
him but he was technically much more
popular than I was but then uh when I
started acting I guess I did one movie
and then my second film was uh Mona Lisa
Smile if anyone remembers that oh my
gosh I love that one and I have to dance
with Julia Roberts in this movie damn
and so they said like were you like
before filming starts I was already just
terrified to meet her they're like will
you come do a ballroom dancing class
with Julia Roberts and I was like this
is my shot
it's like everything I learned in that
too oh here we are uh dancing
it's me and my uh
yeah yeah I was so scared I stepped on
her toes like a couple times and she was
very cool about it and then uh when we
did it on the day the whole cast was
also dancing on the dance floor and
again I won't use his name but I told
her this story and Julie Roberts came to
me at the end after the scene and she
high-fived me and she goes that was for
Frank and I was like
ah we can't stand Frank whoever you are
Frank you know who you are yeah bullying
isn't cool
it's season three of his show home
economics you can see it Wednesdays on
ABC so you asked to show that clip right
that was the clip you wanted to show
right yes because that episode our
fourth episode takes place in 2009 that
might explain why we looked awesome
awesome that the the swing it was
amazing yeah and they put so much
product in my hair the hair lady was
like don't stand next to any open flames
but uh but we're we're trying to clear
some Kelly Clarkson uh 2009 don't worry
I won't make you agree to anything I
know I'm like well I'll agree what is it
that's the album right what is that My
Life Would Suck Without You oh I should
know this yep oh well I don't listen to
myself that's right yeah that'd be weird
yeah that would be weird if I'm just
like jamming to myself but I think I
listen to it too much but that I'll get
it cleared great yeah all right great
you heard it you're ready
songs can be difficult I have to work
yeah we uh after I came last time I had
such a great time on your show and
Wilmer Valderrama uh had just been on
before me and we were talking about it
and we can't believe that we weren't
hanging out with you like I feel like
2009 was like or mid-2000s like I can't
believe we never crossed pad and why I
said to her I was like I think we would
have like hung out with her I we totally
would have hung out here's the thing
about to know about me I am an extrovert
but also secretly an introvert so like
that just means you're an introvert I
know but I I am an expert I like P like
no it's like once I get to know someone
then I'm like this all the time like I I
think on camera I'm even more outgoing
than I am in life I think that's a lot
of actors that I yeah well I'm not an
actor but musicians are like that too
when was the uh you're singing in the
rain I was talking to your producer
about this like it's like raining
indoors and you're singing it like MTV
Movies no but you know it's like oh
that was the VMAs that's like the
greatest performance of all time like it
was that's up there for me with like
Prince Super Bowl no sorry I don't mean
to
that is that's a great performance right
okay but I mean you can even admit that
was a great well no what's so funny is
that maybe you've done this in your
career too when people tell you you
can't do something and then just live
you do whatever you want oh what
happened they said you can't I wasn't I
wasn't supposed to be a part of the rain
they were like Oh no you're not allowed
to do that I don't know if it's
liability or whatever but then it was
like I didn't tell them so nobody was
held accountable only myself but I just
went in the rain anyway because I was
like this is not cool it'd be more fun
to be a part that moment it was a lot
harder to sing in here though but yeah
that moment was like like the reality
show and that was such a huge hit but it
was like is it gonna happen and that was
the moment where it went like poop and
then it like happened right yeah that
was no it was I just did it yeah yeah
you don't do you have moments like that
when people tell you you shouldn't do
something whatever and you're like I'm
just gonna do me no now that I'm married
uh no more of those no moments
check with her
you could call to make sure it's okay
so wait your show is a comedy I love
it's hilarious but it deals with real
topics which I think is important
um like how income equality inequality
rather is an issue is that is that a
huge and it's it's amazing to me one
that there has there aren't that many
shows about that when that's such a big
deal to all of us but I love when you
take an important topic and then you add
humor oh yeah it's hard I mean the
writer's job is hard but it's based on
uh Mike Colton who runs the show with
John abood you're like a writing team
but Mike it's based on his life so
anything that we're doing on the show
wow has been is like except for
something that happens this is uh maybe
a spoiler but uh
Community we find out we have another
sibling
and it's like a it's like a really
interesting way into this bot but it's
my favorite thing of this I can't tell
you who it is or what the but it's like
these writers are so good on this show
and it's so inventive and it's so
another serious situation that is like
done with a lot of humor and like I just
I love it I love being with a cast it's
such a fun show you know and I love that
you point that out and I you're such a
great human too because a lot of people
that come here don't always mention the
writers and the writers are so important
for those plots those storylines no but
they're the whole thing but look at all
the whole thing they really should be
able to implement what's happening
they're way more than the actors no I
don't think that but I just think it's
it's a it's amazing though that like
when you work with Incredible writers
and you're inspired both they're doing
and it makes your job more exciting
right the same thing as a singer like no
grid yeah yeah that's cool I love when
people come up with great storylines
that's awesome well there's this photo
that um exists from the very from the
very early days of That 70s Show do you
remember this uh yeah okay so why don't
you and how's the man that skinny eating
that many Burger like I'm just like what
kind of medicine are you on your
producer you're a great producer Craig
Thomas Jeff who is in charge of my
segment was my first interview of all
time that's from people's
40 fabulous faces of something I don't
know but like
he did that he he didn't take the
pictures okay but I didn't know anything
I can't look at this
here's what I keep the picture up okay
here's what I want to tell Craig by the
way because I love him and he's great
but also like no one told me I had a say
in like what the concept like you know
no like when you do a photo shoot like
hey maybe I won't be eating like 10
minutes
or like what's the like what's the
thinking behind the suit what are we
doing what are we doing here but I just
like did this interview with Craig it
was very gentle he was my first and I
uh
and then when I was when I was preparing
for this segment I got to talk to him I
was uh I was just really really happy to
reunite with him and like you know I
mean my mom like you know clipped it out
and put in my pillow and I can't it was
like a big deal for the grace family I
love that I had this moment too I did
ridiculous things yeah then it and
you're just like you don't know you're
green right so I was like I'll do
anything yeah they got us I did they got
us they got both they got it that's okay
we made it who won again who won in the
end
[Music]
[Applause]
y'all have a great night I'm going
[Music]